Oh finally I found my passion you know
it's um it's true calling for me when
I'm on stage I feel great and I love it
LuAnn de Lesseps is officially a cabaret
star he met up with the singer as she
prepped for the new leg of her countess
and friends tour at Feinstein's 54 below
in New York City
she's also launching season 11 of the
Real Housewives of New York City this
season how are you feeling about it
knowing what you filmed oh well I I
personally think it's a great season for
me in terms of I'm doing what I like to
do and what makes me happy and and
that's my cabaret show and you know some
might differ fans missed out on seeing
Lou at the season 10 reunion as she took
time away from the spotlight to re-enter
a treatment facility
did she come to this decision herself
was there an intervention do you I mean
I would say that she did not come to
this decision entirely on her own there
are a few people there and it was the
right thing to do you're sober today
well I'm just over six months sober
Wow seven months so that's a big deal
yeah it's it's you know it's I continue
to make that the most important thing in
my life because it is and I'm feeling
really good and I'm doing really well so
I'm I'm happy I take a day-by-day
sobriety is important to me and it just
changes everything for me in terms of my
happiness and living my best life so the
season starts out kind of rehashing
where we left things off some stuff went
down with your kids yes is it going to
be tough to have to revisit that time
watching it all back it's part of my
past I'm go
to say I mean I'm still you know dealing
with the fallout of what happened in
Palm Beach my kids and I are fine and
everything's great between us which I'm
so grateful for because look more
important than family there is nothing
more important to me so everything is
good with my children and you know to
watch it playback yeah it's not easy but
I went through that and I'm through that
now and so so the future is very
positive for me in terms of in terms of
taking care of myself and and my family
everything is really good and I feel
really good and I'm continuing to do my
cap ratios which are selling out so you
know everything is good nine months ago
I was in jail and now I'm a cabaret star
the beginning of the season it seems
like you and Bethenny are in a really
good place but then the trailer makes it
seem like maybe that falls it takes a
left turn at some well you know we we
have our disagreements Bethenny and I
and you know you're gonna see some of
those happening on the show and but you
know that thing's been great to me and
very helpful and in terms of helping me
through this difficult time in my life
and I really appreciate that of course
you know I'm I'm there for Bethenny and
she's been there for me in a big way and
so you know when you have traumatic
things like that happened in your life
you know girlfriend support you and
that's you know that's what you're gonna
see you're gonna see support and then
you're gonna see whatever is going to
unfold as usual housewives bring it back
to the Cabaret
number one reason why the fans should
come out and see it when it gets to
their town our town near them oh my god
well the Cabaret is full of fun
antidotes stories I love to tell jokes I
love to sing and I love to invite my
friends and be the hostess so you have
to come out into my living room and
catch the show you feel happy when you
leave the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]